Alexander is a machine learning
researcher educator consultant and
author and in this talk he's going to be
discussing causality and
python thank you so much Aisha for the
introduction uh so the title of the talk
is the caal toolbox a practical guide to
cality in Python for the perplexed who
feels perplexed about
causality oh it's not that many
people okay
um out of the people who are not
perplexed about causality who knows
about pean
framework not that okay so it's four
people so the rest of you is somewhere
in
between I want to start it with uh
introducing you
to this guy
he's a chimp and his name was Santino he
used to live in fuik zoo in Sweden and
died tragically last year shot by uh by
people in in a very unfortunate
accident uh Santino was very typical in
certain
regards as he was a male chimp he was
showing
dominance so dominance display is a set
of behaviors that male
chimps uh that M chimps
display to show the dominance and one of
those behavior is Stone throwing so as
you can see there are some people
gathering around the island where he was
was where he was living he was just
throwing stones at those people to show
that he's the
boss well that's uh good for the chimp
but not so good for the people as they
can get hurt
so the workers the zoo workers were
hiding the stones from
him and that's also typical what was not
typical about Santino was that even that
they searched the island very carefully
and they were convinced they found all
the stones that he could use as
projectiles he was still throwing
stones the story became famous thanks to
Matias osat who's a cognitive scientist
from the University of
Lun and it turned out that
Santino was not only throwing the Rocks
but he was also very carefully planning
what he will do and he was planning in
advance which means that he was
collecting the Rocks before the zoo was
opened hiding them in a place that he
knew that the Z workers won't look for
them
there and then using them when the when
the time was coming he was also doing
something a little more unexpected he
was also collecting the rocks or parts
of the the concrete parts of the pit
around his Island during the winter time
when the zoo was closed so he was
planning in advance not only a couple of
hours he was able to plan in advance
even a couple of couple of
months the chimpanzee appeared
consistently to combine deceptive
strategies hiding projectiles and
inhibiting display dominance so he was
also behaving very calmly before he
started drawing Stones which is not that
typical for for male
chimps um and you can see that he was
using different types of of stuff so
rocks and also pieces of
concrete the Gathering and Manufacturing
has been observed during the hours
before Theos open and why is this
interesting or relevant for for this
talk today where we are talking about
causality and python it's relevant
because all those actions that he was
able to carry out require something that
we would call a world
model they also require something that
we tend to call contactual reasoning so
contactual reasoning is thinking about
the future
or the past and
Imagining the outcomes of our actions if
we choose one action or another action
and then being able to compare
them so we used to think for many years
that uh prospective memory planning
contactual reasoning are uniquely human
today we know
that chimp chimpanzees are not the only
species that can do
that so yeah so what's why why that's
important for humans this might be
intuitive thinking about future and
thinking about
counterfactuals but when we are trying
to translate it into computer
programs we meet a number of challenges
on our on our
way and I want to talk about this a
little bit more but before this I want
to introduce myself briefly
um I'm a consultant educator and advisor
and a researcher I'm also author of this
book and I took one copy with me for
you there's more than one person
so so what I propose is that among the
people who will be active
today we will write a simple numpy
program to draw the winner is that
okay okay
so who thinks it's okay let's say
okay oh that's powerful thank
you for those of you who won't be lucky
or w't don't want to be active you can
learn more about the book by scanning
this QR code I'm also the leader of the
causal python Community you can learn
more about community and some free
resources
here and privately I love traveling with
my wife and I also enjoy good
food and this is a picture from one of
our trips in Costa
Rica and as you can see there's this big
black thing here at the rear part of the
motorcycle these are all all our
belongings so that day we're traveling
from from the Caribbean coast uh to the
mountains area and we checked the
weather and the weather forecast said
that most likely there will be some rain
on the
road so because we knew that our
bags were were not
waterproof and we also didn't want all
our stuff to be to get wet we bought
those trash
bags and we put our oral belongings in
those in those trash
bags so this is also an example of
counterfactual of counterfactual
reasoning and as we said before for
people there's nothing special about
thinking about hey it will rain this is
not waterproof so I need to do this
action instead of another action to get
to my goal and my our goal here was to
keep our clothes keep our clothes
dry
so when we think about machines and
machine learning and machines learning
learning patterns or learning stuff in
the real world we often think about the
data and even if not
explicitly we often assume that if there
is some variability in the data in one
variable and another variable we can
learn something about
the way those variables are
linked so I want to give you an
example I want to start with a question
how to increase the number of
non-commercial space launches per
year
around a decade
ago this thing this interesting thing
has started that that was that was
called the Big Data Big Data Revolution
and like everybody was on board and I
was on board as well and I remember that
Google published a a paper or a blog
post when where they said if we have
enough data
points we can answer any
question the idea there was that if we
put a expressive enough architecture on
a big enough data set then this
architecture will be able to learn all
relevant patterns in the in in the data
so one
datadriven answer to this question that
you see on the screen is to increase the
number of phds in sociology in the
US is that a good answer
let's get another Elon
[Laughter]
Musk I count this as activity what's
your name elain
Elaine thank you thank
you why why why did I propose this
answer because the data shows that
there's a very strong relationship
between the number of non-commercial
commercial space launchers and sociology
doctorates in the US you can see that
the correlation is well it's pretty
strong and it
holds for over a
decade so in the community in data
Community you will meet people sometimes
who will tell you of course
correlation is not
causation but if we observe consistent
correlations over time this is an
indicator that maybe there is cation
there
as you can see
here and I assume that we agree here
that the
answer uh that the number of Sociology
phds um causes number of non-commercial
space launches is not a good
answer then you can see that this is not
necessarily the
case so traditional machine
learning and I would say traditional
associative machine learning we'll talk
about why associative uh uh why
associative we'll talk about this in in
a second it's great for prediction under
the assumption that uh the future is
like the
past so we say the The Joint
distribution that we used for the
training won't change at test
time it often changes and some people
would propose that for for instance
using like automated ml Ops would be a
solution to this problem it might be
sometimes but in most
cases this traditional associative way
of doing machine learning is
insufficient for decision
making going back to the example of of
of our journey in Costa Rica our trip in
Costa
Rica well predicting that it will rain
is not enough to make a decision what to
do and we will see a more precise
example in a
second all that said traditional
associative machine learning can be very
helpful as a component of a larger
decision making system or a causal
system in causal causal modeling or why
we even think about causal
modeling is
because we want to understand what will
happen if we make a certain action in
the world or as we sometimes call it we
intervene in the
world so we can imagine what's your name
Suri
Suri we can imagine that Suri has a
headache today I hope it's not
true and somebody comes to Suri and
gives her a a painkiller she takes it
and one hour from now her headache is
gone we can ask a question now is
was was the painkiller the cause of su
headache going
away and one intuitive answer is that
yes because we know something about
painkillers we know something about the
time it takes for them to
work but uh it's not necessarily the
case right maybe she's sensitive to
atmospheric pressure and the pressure
has
changed or maybe there's something else
maybe this was just a place placebo
effect so you were
just
um convinced that it will work and it
worked this
way so traditional associative machine
learning cannot help us answer those
questions in particular those questions
might have a form like this if we do X
will it change
y or will y be larger if we do
X or if we abstain from doing it
and you might think that there's a
problem with this what what do you think
could be a problem with all of this
trying to answer those
questions yesing variables confounding
factors
confounding X without understanding what
A and C are doing M what's your name SE
SE
yes yeah so confounding variables so
there might be some variables that are
changing the the X and changing y but if
we are able to control X and we
know how to control it and why we
control it and when we control it for
instance if we randomize X then we can
get rid of those confining variables but
that was a very good answer thank
you there's another problem with this
now we can never observe all potential
outcomes
so Suri cannot take the peel and not
take the peill at the same time
right this is called the fundamental
problem of causal inference as Paul
Holland called it in
1986 and this means for us that we need
to somehow simulate at least one of the
outcomes so we said a little little bit
about causality but we haven't defined
it so what actually is causality this is
one of the definitions that I found on
the internet it comes from Wikipedia in
particular from the article that
discusses causality in the context of
physics is it a good
definition um consequence something is
the consequence of something else MH
it's the same as this
Pro
probably so do you think it's a good
definition
or I'm have a feeling that you don't
think
so but that's not the
question but it seems it sounds right it
sounds right yes okay why does it sound
right uh because it has the words
relationship and causes and impacts in
it mhm great thank you
okay we have some more voices here it
has the limitation for our purposes that
it's by Direction which is okay in
physics because nearly all the
fundamental equations are time symmetric
M that is actually one of the
fundamental problem at the basis how you
choose the direction for
time so if I understand you correctly
you're saying that there is no
indication of of Direction
directionality
here what's your name Tedd Tedd
K Kevin
Kevin thank you Kevin that's a good one
so we could argue that if somebody says
says causes and effects then we we would
say that causes are before effects right
but it's not explicitly stated here no
and and this leads us to another uh
problem with this definition but we have
another voice there say what about like
uh Second Law thermodynamics are like
the motion towards entropy not
uh table and it breaks you're increasing
entropy that's only one directional yeah
that would be an example of actual cause
it's not symmetrical yes what's your
name Josh
Josh thank you Josh so Josh said to
those of you who maybe were not able to
catch this that hey what's about the
second law of Thermodynamics and there
is this inherent notion of of
entropy of entropy increasing in One
Direction that's a very good intuition
as well um okay we could also say that
this definition is circular right so it
says the causality causality is defined
here using causes and causes well we we
still don't know what it
is so maybe this definition doesn't say
us doesn't tell us uh that much so can
we do better cality is a topic that was
discussed in virtually every culture in
the world if you look through ancient
Chinese text you will find uh people
thinking about causality you will find
it in um in Muslim texts you will find
it in Jewish texts and virtually any
other culture in the world that left
some uh textual textual Heritage you
will find people talking about causality
of course also Aristotle and All Greek
philosophy was vividly interested in
this topic the problem with
uh the definitions that we can find in
those texts often religious or early
philosophical text are that these
definitions are not very
actionable so maybe people captured some
interesting intuitions
there and I think it's worth to study
those texts because sometimes you can
learn very interesting things about how
people in different cultures
perceived
um how we can act in the world and what
does it mean but it's not really
actionable so the definition that I want
to propose for today comes from judia
Pearl and it says a is a cause of B if B
listens to
a this a very simple definition we can
call it Interventional in a sense that
we talk about taking
action or doing an interven vention in
the world and observing the
outcome listens to means that we expect
that if we change something in a
something in B will also
change and as you can
see this already is somehow conceptually
different from this idea of associations
that we discussed in the beginning
because here we talk about the
action and we'll see in a second why
this is important
so this is a so-called the ladder the
so-called ladder of
causation that comes from also from Juda
Pearl's
works it has free
runs we can think about this lad of
causation as a useful
metaphor that helps us grasp certain
Concepts uh related to causality more in
an intuitive sense but it's
also uh a formal system that can be
defined
precisely in measure theoretic way and
topological way we won't discuss it
today because we don't have time
um but we will discuss the more
intuitive VI so the first rank is
Association and each
rank has an action that is related to
this rank so Association is is related
to obser to
observing looking at the world and
seeing that maybe some things in the
world are changing
together then we have interventions
which is acting in the world and seeing
what happens if we change something and
finally we have
counterfactuals that we discussed
briefly in the beginning and
counterfactuals or counterfactual Reason
is related to
imagin so we
imagine this alternative world for
instance the alternative world where you
did not take the pill and we are
comparing the outcomes in this
alternative world to the outcomes that
we observe today and this might s might
sound like a scientific
Voodoo because what is it just dreaming
about
something but it turns out that
theactual have a precise formal
definition or a set of formal
definitions so we can talk about each of
the ranks here in a mathematically
rigorous
way and so the apparatus that we
mathematical apparatus that we we use
for each ranks here we will just use
correlations or some generalizations of
correlation that could be information
theoretic measures very very general but
they still look at
associations between two or more
variables then at the Interventional
level we will use uh we'll start using
stuff like do calculus or we'll start
using stuff like uh structural caal
models and so on and so on and
counterfactuals we only use structural
causal
models that will need to have the
richest representations of all of this
so another way to think about this is
that Association
for associations the data itself is
sufficient for Interventional
distributions we need some exter
external information that is beyond the
data now
sometimes sometimes we will be able to
make Interventional conclusions from
observational data but we will we'll
need to make certain assumptions and
finally for counterfactuals we will need
the richest information so we also need
some external information but the
representation will need to be richer
than in ter than in the case of of
interventions okay so how can we
translate all those beautiful abstract
ideas into something uh practical we
started with this idea of the definition
of causality from Judea Pearl a is a
cause of B if B listens to
a and per on frame workk comes with a
set of
tools that we can use to translate to
translate this mathematical formalisms
into something more practical one of the
tools are
graphs they look very
simple we often use uh dtic ayli graphs
or
dags but most of the things that we will
discuss today can be generalized to
either either
cyclic
or not fully directed cases as
well so let's see a quick
example how this may work how this might
work and
how we would be able to
translate between those
graphical representations and and their
properties and statistical properties of
the
data so I want us to imagine a fire
alarm and we have only three variables
in this system there is alarm there is
smoke and there is fire and we
assume that the
alarm is based on a smoke particle
detector which means that it it won't um
react to temperature temperature changes
or I don't know fire itself it will only
react to fire through the
smoke a system like this could be
represented by by by a graph like this
we fire which causes smoke and smoke
causes alarm we can assume it's
deterministic or we can say it's there
is some stochastic noise in the system
as well let's talk about deterministic
just for the case of Simplicity for the
sake of
Simplicity and now what is interesting
about this
graph nothing is also an answer yes yeah
fire isn't directly connected to
alarm fire is not directly connected to
alarm that the fire is not directly
connected to alarm yeah I yeah I think
this is a very interesting property why
is that
interesting well
because I I know I guess where I think
where it's going is that the smoke is
cantly Al to go up not the fire
mhm and okay we call it a fire alarm
should be like a smoke
alarm not my choice what's your name
susha
susha for me it's just uh I opened my
oven alarm
so
yeah yeah the other thing that's
interesting is from that graph you can
make the inference
from the alarm that there is a
fire again again to make an inference
from that from the alarm the alarm goes
off there is a fire because there is a
direct caal relationship unless
something elsea the
smoke yeah and that's both both are very
good very good intuitions thank you
thank you so one thing that is I think
we already implicitly said this here and
here one thing that is very interesting
here is that if we look at this at smoke
if we observe smoke the alarm and fire
become become
independent which means that if we if
there is smoke and the alarm goes off
there's
nothing the fire is it's independent of
fire okay if we think about this in in
the terms of regression you will see
this so the all information that in
other words I will give you another
perspective on this all information from
fire goes through smoke so if we know
that there's
smoke the fact if there is a fire won't
change anything for the alarm maybe you
just open the
ovens what's your
name and this property translates to any
system that has this structure
and this structure is called a
chain which means that a and c will
become independent given
B now we could change some arrows here
to get another structure for instance
this one a
fork what will happen with A and C if we
control for
B yes
A and C they will be like correlated
they are
like so so you said they will be
correlated but independent in which case
yeah so they they will have the a
correlated outcome but they don't close
each other yes and if we control for b
or if we don't control for
B so you said they will be correlated
but they don't cause each other which is
true because we see that the arrows go
in the other direction
um what's your name oliv
Olivia if they would appear correlated
until you control
forp that's a very good answer what's
your name Scott
Scott yes so as you can see B is a
common cause of A and C which means that
there is some change in a and change in
C
that comes from
B and those changes are correlated
because they come from one
thing ah thank
you so if we exclude this or we partial
it out for instance in the regression
framework there will be no common
variability left in a and
C now we have another structure is
called a
collider what would happen with A and C
so what what is the relationship between
a and C if we don't control for B and
what will happen if we control
for yes you control for it they become
correlated if we control for B they will
become correlated and and what if we
don't control then they shouldn't be
correlated they shouldn't be Corr what's
your name Danny Dan yeah yeah
Dan thank you Dan and that's the correct
answer and this is a very important fact
because you can see now that if we
run conditional dependence or
conditional Independence
tests we cannot distinguish between
those two of course we are talking about
a situation where we don't know the
arrows the direction of the arrows but
we can distinguish between those two
forks and chains and
colliders because a and c will behave
differently
if we control for B versus do not
control for B then they will behave for
FK and
chain and this also translates to
statistical properties so you can see
for
chains a is not a significant uh so so C
is the outcome here in those regressions
and a and b are predictors if we control
for B in the chain B is a significant
predictor of C but a is not the same is
the case for fork a significant
predictor B not significant
a but for
collider although a and C are not Cal
related a and and C are significantly
related and this has tremendous
uh impact on the outcome of any
statistical
model in terms of feature selection
so we know that we have automated
feature selection algorithms that we use
in machine learning traditionally they
work very well and again this is one of
the reasons why this feature selection
will only work well or the models with
the feature selections will only work
well in the IID setting because if we
change something in the underlying joint
distribution then the
model will have predictors in it that
are not causally related to the outcome
and so the
distribution will not map to what is
happening in the real
world and so if you want to learn more
about this particular aspect there's a
great paper on this by Carlos chinelli
Andrew for and judia pearl just from
last year and one of the effects why
this is important or what one of the
reasons why this is important is this
this comes from from my book and I will
I will say this very briefly so here if
we control for a variable one variable
in the model we might either get a
result that drag
a is better for sorry that drag B drag B
is better for
everyone but it's worse for males and
females but if we
change the feature selection in the
model the drug becomes bad for everybody
but it becomes good for males and for
females and this is so-call Simpsons
Paradox and this means
that statistical
control without thinking about the
causal structure behind it the data
generating process as we call it
sometimes will lead to the
outcomes that are are not representative
of
reality and this is something we
recently hear about a lot in the context
of large language models when we ask
those models about factual information
and we get complete very plausibly
sounding but complete
gibberish but it turns out that we don't
need a very complex uh architecture like
llms regression is
enough so we can get statistically
significant results in linear
regression with very very low
uncertainty that completely do not
translate to
reality and if you want to learn more
about this you can see this is uh the
podcast that we released just two days
ago it's called coal Bandits and we talk
with some great researchers and
practitioners in the field you can check
it here okay we have very little time so
we have to run very quickly now the four
steps of causal inference so how we
translate those ideas into practice um
well first we need to model the problem
and this is something that is different
from treditional machine learning
because we need to say something about
the data generating
process then we are finding the
estimate what is an
estimate something you use to estimate
something you use to estimate something
something yes something we used to
estimate something which is basically
finding a quantity that we want to
estimate so in machine learning we'll
just say hey we are interested in the
expected value of y given x a set of
predictors but here if you want to
translate causal queries into
statistical language we will have to
very carefully construct this expression
this conditional
expression uh to do
it so this is the estimate and there are
many
estimates um and they encode our causal
model of the world our our belief and
then we are Computing
estimates and finally we are validating
the model so here we have some
code which we which we will go through
very
briefly and
and we'll use a package that is called
DOI and then at the end of this notebook
you will also have another package that
is called econ ml so these are some
helper functions here we are generating
some
data and then you can see that we are
constructing this graph and the graph is
representing the data generating process
here we construct it manually but we
don't have to always construct it
manually we can try to automate
it we are not the we are not yet in a
place where we can completely automate
it from observational data but we can
partially
automated and then there is a class in
DUI called caal Model that takes the
data information about which variable is
the treatment which variable is the
outcome and it also takes this extra
statistical information which is the
graph which represents our belief
regarding the data generating process we
can view a model like this so here we
can see that we have one unobserved
confounder here we cannot observe this
variable we know it's there but we
cannot observe it we have X that is our
treatment y that is our outcome and we
have this variable in the middle which
is z it's a mediator yeah you can figure
this yeah I'll try
is that
okay and so now there is a set we we we
mentioned briefly do calculus in the
beginning which is a set of rules how to
translate uh causal queries into
statistical ones and do I can find for
us automatically the way how to do this
translation not in every case but in
some cases we use this identify effect
function on the model object and you can
see that it only currently supports
three types of estimates first is back
door and it says no such variables found
second is IV which stands for
instrumental variable also not
found but luckily pump the estimate the
front door estimate there's a expression
a symbolic expression it also list the
assumptions and then when we have this
estimate we found this we can use
use the estimator to estimate the effect
and in our data I won't show you because
we don't have too much time the true
effect was minus 42 so let's see how
well it
did Min -
0441 rounding up so this is this is
pretty close if we would run a
traditional machine learning model on
this and try to estimate this effect and
then change something in the under like
distribution this model would go out
very very
quickly and finally we have this idea of
refutation
test which is a I would say it's a
weak it's a weak way of of validating
the model in particular the assumptions
part of the model the assumptions about
the data generating process why I say
it's weak because it changes something
either in the model or in the data and
see and checks if the outputs are as
expected so some methods of reputation
tests will we would expect that the
effect is change is is changed for some
other methods we'll expect that it's not
changed so here for instance we just
take a subset refuter so we take a
subset of the
data we rerun the models it runs a lot
of a a lot of iterations in the
background
and it gives do the result the new
effect
is minus 041 and P value is very high
which which says it's insignificant
which in this case says that there are
no
violations um in our model that would
lead for this particular test to fail so
this is just a very weak way of
validating the
models and then we have also something
so so so so far we are talking about the
general
effect like when we run an RCT a
randomized control
trial we
will try to estimate what is an average
effect of something on certain
population but sometimes we might be
interested in effect for a particular
subgroup of
people and so you can check it here in
this code um and that would be for
[Applause]
you